in George Orville's 1984 the government
is trying to force Britain or rather
airstrip one to use Newspeak a
constructed language that would end
thought crime the goal so The Story Goes
is to make it impossible to form ideas
that could challenge the ruling Party by
taking away the words to thank them with
linguists often cringe when they hear
people talk about the idea that the
language you speak determines how you
can think because it's
well it's not really a thing it's been
called The sapir Wharf hypothesis
because it's associated with Benjamin
Lee Wolff an early 20th century linguist
and his mentor Edward sapier they
weren't the first the last or the
loudest linguists to ask the question
and they never wrote anything even close
to a hypothesis about it together they
wondered how language could impact
thought and vice versa but no more than
that the concept is known as linguistic
determinism in its strong form and
linguistic relativism in its weak form
determinism the strong version is a
popular Trope in fiction particularly
science fiction
ah which is where it belongs the film
arrival made it a major plot point and
actually name checked it if you immerse
yourself into a foreign language then
you can actually rewire your brain yes
hypothesis
the short story it's based on is much
better linguistic determinism is not
taken very seriously by the Linguistics
Community as it's easily disprovable
either by attending a philosophy 101
course or just thinking about the phrase
I wish I could find the words to explain
how I feel but the weak form linguistic
relativism is much more broadly accepted
it is a difficult and messy thing to
test for and prove though you can find a
lot of people claiming that the Russian
language has no word for privacy because
the concept of privacy isn't part of
traditional Russian culture that might
be true I'm not Russian couldn't tell
you but that wouldn't be language
limiting the way you think that would be
language reflecting the way you think
there have been studies that show things
like German speakers whose language says
that key is masculine are more likely to
describe a key as Jagged rough and hard
whereas Spanish speakers where he is
feminine would be more likely to use
Golden or intricate I've referred to
that exact study here in the past but
since then other researchers have tried
to replicate it and they didn't find the
same result which is something that
keeps happening across psychology and
other fields and besides it's very
difficult to tease apart the impacts of
your culture and the impact of your
language even if that result is true
which it's probably not is the gendered
language the cause or the effect
there are some clear impacts on how
different languages not cultures affect
the brain for example our hearing tunes
into the phonology the sounds of the
languages we speak in Hindi for example
tal and tal are two different words
platter and Rhythm because ter and are
considered different sounds based on the
aspiration the air that comes out that's
not a cultural value that's not ideology
it's not passed down deliberately to
children
that's just language if you speak a
language with that distinction your
brain will hear it automatically and
unconsciously and if you don't you have
to try to actively listen for it that's
a pretty clear way that languages impact
thought but that doesn't feel close
enough to the science fiction does it
it's it's not like it's changing your
understanding of the world science
fiction wants the language you speak to
affect the categories in your head the
way you understand the world
particularly for abstract Concepts
rather than actual physical things so
what about emotions
emotions do get categorized in different
ways by different humans all over the
world in English we can use the same
word for two different feelings if
someone says I'm sad do they mean crying
in the corner or depressed tired and
staying in bed those are both sad in the
same way that the sky and ocean are both
blue but if a child only knows the word
sad they've not heard of despondent or
listless or morosa on we or the
underlying emotions are still different
they can still tell whether someone's
grieving the devastating loss of their
cartoonishly large lollipop or whether
they're just tired and generally down
having the different words is really
helpful for expressing yourself but they
don't determine your ability to feel
emotions and ancient Greek had a lot of
words for love in English those are all
basically translated as love with a lot
of extra notes but even though we only
have one basic word to explain all those
feelings and emotions we still
experience them and we can communicate
them without knowing ancient Greek just
takes a few words until recently English
did not have a word for feeling Joy at
someone else's Misfortune but we still
definitely experienced it before we
borrowed schadenfreude from German
so the simple answer to the question is
no not really it might change how you
listen to sounds it might make some
things easier to explain but the idea
that you can stop people bringing down
the government by changing their
language is
thankfully just fiction
and if you want even more Linguistics my
cohort aggression McCulloch has a
podcast called enthusiasm the link is on
screen and in the description